hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in politics book 1 Aristotle sets out a
set of relations of origin between the
family or the household all the way up
to the city-state the political
community the polis and he also tells us
that the city-state although not
originally prior temporarily is prior in
some other sense to not only the family
or the household but also to individuals
so how does he trace out this connection
or a set of relations between these
different levels going all the way up to
the greatest community for him which is
the political community we have to begin
with the household the Oikos the word
that we actually get economy from is
economic a household management which
he's also going to discuss in this book
of the politics and Aristotle says that
the household has its origin in
something that is natural and goes
beyond human nature to encompass all
sorts of other animals and even plants
where there's sexual dimorphism that is
where reproduction takes place by having
two sexes which need each other in order
for reproduction and which in the case
of animals including us human animals
there's a certain natural affection or
at least desire for engaging in that and
unlike many other animals human beings
don't simply copulate and then go on
their way they form a larger unit and
this is a very important idea for
Aristotle the family or the household is
a whole composed of parts in this case
at the very beginning the part is a man
and a woman and then of course they're
going to have other parts because
they're going to produce children and
there'll be yet other parts
as well the meaning of their existence
exceeds that of their individual
existence by that relation within this
whole this greater unity whereas
Aristotle is going to call it a kono Nia
a sharing a partnership a community and
the household as such starts to become
bigger in terms of having children now
you have a different relation Aristotle
doesn't view sexual relations or gender
relations as inherently egalitarian he
places the man higher than the woman but
he says that it has to be some it can't
be a despotic rule it has to be
something like a aristocratic rule in
some places he says or a political rule
in other places but the relation between
them and children is itself already in
new complexity so within the household
you have those two things going on and
then we have a third dimension which is
that of the relation of free people or
masters and slaves or servants these are
the people who are ruled who are put to
work and Aristotle has an entire
discussion about the ethics of slavery
which we're not going to get into here
suffice it to say that within his model
there's going to be all sorts of things
or persons including among those things
animals which are used for their labor
which are directed by say the head of
the household or by the household
manager which with Aristotle envisions
usually as being a the task of the woman
the wife unless it's delegated to a
steward so all of these are part of a
greater whole and what is the purpose of
this in the case of male and female they
want to get it on and then they want to
take care of their children but why have
servants well because the
goal is to by associating into this
larger framework to take care of life to
live better it's not yet to live the
best life that's reserved for the level
of the polis but it is to live better it
is to live more securely the servant or
slave you might say what are they
getting out of it
Aristotle actually makes an argument
that at least in some circumstances
there are some benefits to the servant
or slave it's better for them to be part
of a workable unit rather than off on
their own
miss managing their own affairs and we
don't need to worry about the ethics of
that right now what we're interested in
is the fact that we have a Koinonia a
community established at the level of
the family and it's its retainers or
servants the animals associated with it
the technology associated with it and
this forms a whole some people view that
as sort of the primary hole of a human
being and they they think either in
terms of individuals or they think in
terms of families Aristotle goes further
Aristotle thinks that this is not yet
sufficient although many people do in
fact live like that in small bands out
there wandering around as nomads or
things like that he does talk about the
nomadic lifestyle before we get to the
level of the polis or the city-state I
think about the city of Athens or the
city of Sparta or Corinth we arrived at
a intermediary level of community that
he calls the kome and we translate this
as village here there are more needs
more human needs that are being met than
within the household
although notice that the kome is
composed all the households and
Aristotle actually says that in its
beginning you might think of the village
as sort of a colony from the household
and a boy goes literally a leaving the
house and setting up a new
so over here so you get enough of that
going on and now there's a greater level
of association of community of Koinonia
of sharing and now you might think about
sharing certain tasks like that of
mutual defense or figuring out if you
need to make a road go somewhere or
associating for some religious rituals
or trade or things along those lines
these people are all connected to each
other and there's a greater degree of
self-sufficiency in the village than
there is in the household according to
Aristotle so the natural progression is
to first have households and then to
develop villages of new forms of
Association then we go to a yet higher
level and this is the one that Aristotle
is most interested in quite frankly the
book is called the politics it's not
called the household or the village
management and that is the city state or
the polis and not all human beings
actually reach this level he talks for
example about the island the fabled
island of the Cyclops where at most they
had households and they don't even
really have villages although you could
see the whole island as one perhaps one
big village and they don't have a lot of
social harmony in fact everybody does
exactly what they want to do and they
rule despotic lis over their children
wives servants all of that why do we
associate in two city-states is this
something irrational that just happens
you plunk a a village down over here in
another village and another village and
boom you've got a city-state in point of
how it actually comes about that there
may be something to that
but Aristotle discerns a greater set of
values being enacted safeguarded even
talked about within a city-state that
eclipses the village and the household
why is it that we
form a city-state so part of the reason
is that it satisfies greater demands or
requirements needs of human nature
things that we may not in fact be
completely aware at the start that we we
do in fact desire or need but but are
they're implanted within us
Aristotle frames us in terms of no
longer just securing life but securing
the good life toe-out sane to live well
as opposed to merely living so this is a
very important idea there and he tells
us that the city-state is also much more
self-sufficient because it has a greater
level of complexity also because it
involves a different kind of governance
or rule which may include hearing from
many other people and many interests
that it's going to be better capable of
taking care of itself it's also more
self-sufficient in terms of dealing with
other rival city-states or perhaps other
peoples who are still at the level of
the kome the band or the village but
that's not it's its main point he says
here it has attained the limit of
virtually complete self-sufficiency
while it comes into existence for the
sake of life it exists for the good life
and this is where we get to a very
interesting idea on Aristotle's part he
talks about the city-state being
naturally prior now this does not mean
that it's historically prior as if first
there's city-states and only then do
individuals exist or households or
anything like that that's clearly not
the case however the meaning of human
existence and the capacity to realize
what the nature or the point of an
individual life or the existence of the
household or even the village lies
within the city-state and this provides
it with a certain kind of priority a
priority of value or meaning you might
say so he goes on and he tells us here
we go
it's clear the state is prior by nature
to the individual why because the
individual when separate is not
self-sufficient the individual is not
self-sufficient that's why we have
households that's why we have villages
and all the more so city-states
he says he must be related to the whole
state as other parts are to their whole
a person who is incapable of entering
into partnership or who is so
self-sufficient who has out turkey that
they don't have to do so he says really
has no part of a city statement and a
person like that he holds out two
possibilities either they are a god
they're so far beyond the rest of us
that it's no longer necessary or they
are a brute animal incapable of entering
into the fullness of these different
partnerships so it's within the polis
that we human beings can find our
greatest fulfillment and the polis is
composed of parts all the way down to
individuals there are other ways of
course of parsing out the polis when you
read later in the politics you'll see
Aristotle talking about parts in terms
of say the rich and the virtuous and the
many or also in terms of the
institutions within the city-state but
this is also another important way to
think about it because we do tend to
find ourselves within households to some
degree and then smaller level associate
and then larger political associations
so this is an attempt for Aristotle to
sketch out a very rudimentary set of
relations between these different levels
of human association or community
you